plus aucun cargo ne peut décharger d'or
noir russe dans les ports des 27 une
décision prise au mois de mai fruit de
longues semaines de discussion entre
partisans d'un embargo total et les
autres
seuls le pétrole transporté par bateau
et concerné pas celui transporté par
Oléo duc même si certains pays comme
l'Allemagne et la Pologne ont d'ores et
déjà décidé de suspendre également les
livraisons par pipeline d'ici fin
décembre au total 90% des importations
de l'Union européenne seront ainsi
stoppés en plus de cette mesure les
européens se sont mis d'accord avec les
membres du G7 sur un plafonnement du
prix du baril de pétrole russe à 60
dollars un prix jugé beaucoup trop
important par l'Ukraine car trop proche
de celui pratiqué actuellement par les
Russes
ce n'est pas une décision sérieuse de
fixer une telle limite pour les prix
russes qui restent confortables pour le
budget de cet état
ni à la poursuite du parrainage par la
Russie d'autres régimes et organisations
terroristes cet argent sera utilisé pour
poursuivre la déstabilisation des pays
qui tentent maintenant d'éviter les
décisions sérieuses
riche ces mesures devraient être suivies
par d'autres dans les prochains mois
comme un plafonnement des produits
raffinés dont le diesel en février
prochain de quoi attaquer encore un peu
plus la Russie aux porte-monnaies depuis
le début du conflit en Ukraine on estime
que la Russie attiré 67 milliards
d'euros de ses ventes de pétrole à
l'Union européenne tandis que son budget
militaire annuel s'élève lui a une
soixantaine de milliards d'euros